michael panetta dependable
goes out there gives you a chance to win
every time he takes them out
and there's an off speed pitch gets a
swing and a miss nada starts the game
with a strikeout yeah when he's right
that's what it looks like it's
strikes early and then sliders look like
they're going to be in the zone end up
below the zone
good inning for pineda a couple of
strikeouts
and a one two three inning on just nine
pitches jordan lyles this will be a
seventh star last couple
not been great for him the era now back
up over seven and kepler in the lead off
spot
a high blast right center field headed
to the scoreboard
and gone the ninth home run allowed by
jordan lyles and
kepler gets this game started on the
right foot well
quick turnaround after last night but
good quick inning
by panetta set the tone and then
immediately
come out bats come alive and kepler as
we've seen so many times leading off the
game with a home run
missed his spot center cut fastball at
92 miles an hour
kepler does a nice job head down perfect
swing right there driving out of the
ball park
first home run of the year for kepler
now the rangers will get another look
at michael pineda it'll be gallow
that ball hit well center field and
that's gonna carry a long long way it's
gone
well may that be the beginning gallows
fourth homer of the year and we're tied
at one
and it's been great right the quality of
bats like we just talked about the fact
that he's walking not chasing as much
understanding his strengths but it is
also a lot more fun to watch joey gallow
do that when he gets his arms extended
with the great power
that he has and he does here on that
pitch at 91 miles an hour the bottom of
the zone just absolutely tattoos this
thing
for michael pineda 108 miles an hour and
an estimated distance of 434 feet
wow so there you go new ball game and
now garcia
down into that right field corner and
that one takes a big hop garcia
cruises to second he has a double very
different second inning
from the first for the rangers so the
rangers with a chance to break this tie
the twins bring the infield in with one
out for izzy
this one blooped out over first that's
gonna drop in base hit
and get another run home garcia scores
easily from third
and there's a really nice at bat by
kinder philippa doing
all that's needed just to make sure that
run gets home runner goes
strike three gordon with the tag or
simmons rather with the tag
it was gordon with the tag so strike him
out throw him out ends the inning right
bottom half of the third inning top
third of the order do here for the twins
and kepler takes a walk leading off the
third inning
driven to right field that's down for a
hit kepler
will hold up at second base the deal is
up with a chance to tie the ball game
drill to the left field corner kepler
will score buxton right behind him
twins playing a little small ball and
taking advantage of a situation with a
couple guys in scoring position and
oscedo again like a changeup right here
not where he wanted to locate that pitch
give us the deal credit he didn't miss
it he hit it hard and drove in two and
twins retake the lead and a long time
coming for nick gordon
first round pick back in 2014
where's number one he has dealt with so
much off the field had coveted
last year but 2014 danny a long time ago
and finally the dream happens for gordon
today
well that'll leave his mind a whole lot
better than any rap music
his first big league hit after drawing a
walk he fell behind in the second inning
drew a walk and now he lines a single to
right field
yeah he's starting to fill up all the
columns and jk calling for that ball
and he'll throw that into the dugout
though
put that up and he'll be waiting for him
in his locker by the time this game's
over but
congratulations to nick gordon a long
time coming for him and
out front of the change-up right there
but still able to hit a heart hit in the
right spot and
there he goes swung on and missed and
gordon has another steal
kept his foot and something
remained in contact with the base and
he's two for two
in the big league stealing bases halfway
through this one today
3-2 twins leading 2-2 swing and a miss
buxton strikes out on a fastball in 3-2
and got him swinging the inning is over
a strikeout of cino
he leaves two more on base all three
twin starters have pitched
into the sixth inning so far in this
series none of them have been able to
complete that sixth inning see if big
mike's able to do that
and sono to a knee smothers it goes to
the bag
six really good innings for michael
pineda again
and the twins hang on to that one run
lead wins need a game where
they've got a lead and the bullpen lots
things down that's been a huge issue for
this team maybe today is the game
roles has done a nice job the issues
with the bullpen have not centered
around him
three and one count on heim and this one
is
in the air get up out to center field
carrying well
it is gone just got over
buxton with an excellent effort at the
wall
but heim sneaks out his second of the
year to tie the ball game
that would have been absolutely crushing
if byron buxton caught that baseball
because you could tell
for jonah heim when he made contact on
that 96 mile an hour heater
he looked at it like maybe it had a
chance to get out of here it's not a bad
pitch
outer third 96 but heim on time
drilling that thing out to left center
field eighth inning rangers banning
and taylor rogers is on to pitch the
veteran twin
11th round selection back in 2012.
and quickly a strikeout for the first
out of the eighth inning
and gallow strikes out and rogers comes
in and gets two whiffs
of the two left-handed batters wow
a back foot slider that nearly hit the
back foot
pretty impressive outing for taylor
rogers as he strikes out the side
3-3 top nine and the o2 pitch strike
three called inside corner is sinker
four batters faced four strikeouts one
and two
polanco gets one but not two
a nice play by polanco fielding that
ball in the outfield grass
and then midair throwing on target to
simmons
yeah real good play right here and a
hard hit ball
two strikes fly ball left field
garlic is there can the twins walk it
off at home for the second time this
season
tied at three ninth inning taylor hearn
his goal to make sure that there are
extras
chopper to culberson picking it up and
buxton not running well at all to first
base
looked like he maybe had that beat out
and something is not right
with byron buxton i saw it the last time
going up the line this time
you got about two-thirds of the way down
there and then
hold up you hope that's nothing that's
going to be long-term
3-1 we tried the slider and that one
bounces off
of hearn karen's towards second and the
throw to first in time from solac
and we're going to extra innings rangers
three
twins three one strike pitch and that
one bounces away
and heim will head to third what a game
changer these rolls are
yeah right now we're gonna see a
breaking ball that just takes off that
knuckle curve that duffy throws and it's
the pitch that he throws more than any
other
he just yanks it down in the dirt the
one-two pitch swing
and the ball hit past polanco and into
right field that gets jonah heim in from
third
and just like that the rangers lead four
to three
rbi single for willie calhoun his
seventh run
batted in of the season josh force comes
on this is a challenge this is
a lot different than what these guys are
used to immediately your back is against
the wall as you're trying to close out a
game
scores 11 games on the season so far 11
strikeouts
one and two the count for spores looking
for his first
major league save he's done it in the
minor league so he's not unaccustomed to
these kind of spots
and he gets a swing and a miss he
strikes out ostidio
that doesn't happen one away pretty
amazing in a huge spot as you mentioned
here for josh moore's with ian kennedy
down
donaldson just two for 11 in the series
pinch hitting here the o2
swung on and missed strike three foul
tipped it right into the mid
two down really impressive work here
from josh spores
long hold now the pitch to snow and it's
in the air
down into short right field gallow
coming on he dives and makes the catch
just held on to it and the rangers
hold on for another extra innings win
four to three in minneapolis oh
absolutely amazing work there from joey
gal of course we know that he won
the gold glove and perhaps the twins are
going to ask for this to be reviewed
they will why not it's at the end of the
game but you're going to see very
clearly here
that joey gallow dives through this ball
catches it in his glove
holds on to it and this game should be
over
that will be the first career
save for josh spores amazing work
he just